to give us a fuller understanding of how
we can talk
time management with our kids is a dear
friend of mine and a dear friend of the
show
psychology whisperer dr eliza pressman
you know me you know i just can't stand
things like this it just
is so irritating these ridiculous
expectations
god it ruffles my feathers all right
elisa
what is the best strategy for kids to
talk about
time management and just what does a
realistic
list look like in life i would say each
family member needs to figure out what
they actually
will do and carve out a schedule within
those realistic parameters but
make it consistent and make it you know
think of what do i have to do what do i
have to get done
what do i want to get done and let's
just fill that in and
how a day looks manageable and if
there's too much in there
dump it i have to say though
that when you talk about consistency
i actually feel like less of a failure
and more
of a success because i have lived a very
consistent life we
wake up you know they used to go to
school
we now have home school
they have lunch and dinner at the same
time the routines the places
all extremely consistent bath time
bedtimes rituals like books
at bedtime is that
is that what you mean by consistency
yeah i mean what you're talking about
routines and making sure
that there are reliable routines kids
can count on
that's consistent and that helps you
feel less
unsafe in an uncertain world so the
familiar
repetitive sort of understanding of how
my day goes is good and healthy for
children
and the truth is as much as i'm a
rebellious rule breaker and i can't
stand that like perfect
you know stigma of you got to do it this
way
i really do want the very best for my
kids
and for me the very best is the safest
i love that you just said safe that's
the key word and it's only safe if
you're comfortable with it and a safe
schedule is what you want
one that you can feel like is a warm
blanket of
i know what to expect here well i know
what to expect with you
and that's always salient advice that
again somehow that you do it without
judgment but you give
really specific tips on like
somehow it doesn't feel like do's and
don'ts it feels like we find a way to go
i am doing some of these things
therefore i might be doing some things
right and
parents need to feel that way they need
to hear that because we don't feel that
way
i mean we just want it that those do's
and don'ts are the problem
that's that's our problem as an in as a
parenting space it should be do
you and make sure that within the within
the doing you
you're making you're conscious of how
that will support your kids
gosh i can't thank you enough elisa i
just love you so much
[Music]
you